YURI GRINSHTEYN: Whether
you are debugging
a specific application
or monitoring
multiple applications across
several production clusters,
you need logs.
I'm here today to show you how
to use Cloud Logging to easily
find and analyze
the logs you need
from your applications
running on GKE.
This is "The Stack Doctor."
Cloud Logging is deeply
integrated into GKE.
That means that collecting
infrastructure and application
logs is easy.
GKE deploys a
per-node logging agent
that automatically collects
standard output and error logs.
It then sends logs to the
logs router, which sends them
to Cloud Logging and any of
the logging sink destinations
that you have configured.
You can start viewing your logs
as soon as your application is
deployed.
The easiest place
to find the logs
is in the Logs Viewer
in the Cloud Console.
You can get there by selecting
that option from the products
menu.
Another way to access logs just
for your service quickly is
from the GKE Workloads screen.
Just select your deployment
and then click Container Logs.
Either option brings
you to the Logs Viewer.
Note that we're looking at
the Logs Viewer Preview.
You may be more familiar with
the classic Logs Viewer, which
has less functionality.
The new Logs Viewer
has four main areas--
the query builder at the top,
the histogram below that,
the logs field explorer
on the left, and the query
results on the right.
The query builder is at
the top of the screen.
This is how you
create and run queries
to retrieve the
logs that you want.
You can also add query
parameters directly
and use the autocomplete
to select available fields.
The logs field
explorer on the left
is there so that you can
easily find logs by the field
and value in the log payload.
One example would be to look at
all the pods in the namespace.
Since I'm looking at logs for
a specific service already,
I can click on Error
in the Severity field
to find just the error
logs for that service.
Let's do this now.
The histogram at the
top of the screen
shows the frequency
and relative volume
of the errors you're seeing.
You can also use the histogram
to select specific time
ranges to search for.
The query results show
the actual log entries
that match our filters.
You can expand any of the
entries in the results
to see the full log payload.
I'm seeing the authentication
error in my logs.
Finally, you can click on
any of the payload fields
and select Show Matching Entries
to see all log entries that
contain this message if you
want to see where else you may
be getting a particular error.
You've now learned how logs
are ingested from your GKE
workloads into Cloud
Logging and how
to use the Logs Viewer
and its field explorer
and histogram features to
find exactly what you're
looking for.
I hope this helps you to
debug and troubleshoot
your own workloads on GKE.
Thanks for watching.
And come back soon for more.
This is "The Stack Doctor."
Stay healthy out there.